acting homeland security secretary chad
wolfe joins us now mr secretary good
morning thanks for being with us
as you just heard and saw the mayor of
portland was tear gas
last night while he was meeting with
protesters and the protests themselves
seem to have gotten larger
since the your agents went in are they
actually inflaming the situation
no absolutely not what we know is before
dhs law enforcement civil law
enforcement officers arrived in portland
the mayor is on record as saying that
the city
is on it has a certain level of violence
it's been it was ongoing well for a
month before we arrived
the mayor has been very outspoken on
that so just as it was before dhs
arrived
it was very violent and it continues to
be very violent i'm very concerned
that the mayor chose an audience
there are both peaceful protesting going
on in portland and then very
violent criminal activity going on in
portland
and the mayor chose to go to that
violent activity he has legitimized
criminal behavior by doing that he could
have chosen to go to peaceful protesting
had a audience there and could have made
his points he chose to go to an
area that has seen 54 nights of criminal
activity
targeting a federal courthouse and
targeting federal law enforcement
officers so
again i i call on local and state
leaders to work with the department of
homeland security
we want to work with you we want to
bring this violence to a close in a
peaceful manner
but we see the opposite from state and
local leaders there well why do you
think they don't want you there mr
secretary
well again i think there's confusion on
what we are doing in portland we are
there to protect the federal courthouse
we have that responsibility given to us
by the united states congress
we are on that federal property and we
are protecting that federal property
what makes portland so different from
every other country we protect over
almost nine thousand facilities across
the country portland is the only city
where
a protester can stand i'm sorry a
violent criminal could stand on the
other side of the street
and lob a molot cocktail at the
courthouse
and there's no repercussion for that
from a law enforcement perspective
they need to do their job they need to
enforce the law they need to work with
us
and make sure that we hold cr violent
criminals accountable
uh for criminal activity mr secretary
the oregon attorney general said that
masked federal agents have arrested
people on streets
far from the courthouse with no probable
cause and whisked them away in unmarked
cars
is that accurate it's not accurate again
we continue to
battle misleading headlines and just
inaccurate reporting
so again we have a a a direction from
not only the congress but it's in
federal statute we protect that
courthouse
and we have the ability to make arrests
on individuals
that are committing criminal acts now we
normally don't do that in any other city
in the country
because we have state and we have local
law enforcement that is partnering with
the federal government and they make
those arrests as they should however
we are not seeing that in portland so
that's causing that's uh requiring the
federal government to go out
a block two blocks maybe three blocks
from that courthouse
uh so you aren't going beyond the
courthouse you are going beyond the
courthouse that's it
and we have the absolutely expressed
right and authority to do that it's in
our charter it's in federal statute
that we have the ability to do that now
what we're not doing is we're not going
to the other side of portland we're not
going
uh beyond the immediacy of that federal
courthouse
to arrest individuals but mr secretary a
dozen mayors
of major cities in this country have
called this an abuse of power
they're not alone the first secretary of
homeland security
tom ridge said the department was
established to protect americans from
global terrorism
it was not established to be the
president's personal militia
secretary chertoff who succeeded him
with
president george w bush also a
republican by the way
said it appeared the dhs appears to be
overstepping its mission and this is
very
unsettling a lot of people think you're
overstepping your mission here
well i appreciate the service of both
secretary ridge and secretary chertoff
but they're they're wrong on this point
they need to understand exactly what's
going on and i think that's
unfortunate that most americans don't
understand
the violent criminal activity that is
occurring in portland from midnight to 5
a.m
every night and early morning these are
again not peaceful protests department
of homeland security
has no concerns we've seen 54 straight
days of peaceful protest in portland and
you haven't heard of any
incidents we don't make arrests there
there's no concern there
it's this violent activity we have over
last night two thousand individuals
showing up in black all black wearing
masks
having incendiary devices fireworks
lobbing that at
law enforcement officers this is violent
activity it's criminal activity
and will continue to enforce the law at
the courthouse
in portland what directive did you give
your agents when you sent them in
they had the the same directive from the
federal protective service
which is the service within the
department that protects over those 9
000
federal facilities across the country
any law enforcement civil law
enforcement
officer that goes into portland is under
the direction of federal protective
service they do training
and they they are under uh their
leadership so i have given them no
direction federal protective service the
director there the deputy director
the on-scene director they are uh
controlling
uh the the actions of dhs law
enforcement officers there and i would
say just one other thing to
answer your previous question about
other mayors and other
folks that are concerned we are not
sending any other dhs
law enforcement officers to guard
federal courthouses like we are
in portland why because every other city
in america
knows if you work with the federal
government uh you can
you can secure your city and we see that
time and time again
it's as if uh here in d.c it's as if
someone would walk up to the united
states capitol
try to burn it down and then walk to the
other side of the street and say
sorry you can't touch me that is what's
going on in portland and it's wrong but
mr secretary the president is talking
about sending agents into
other cities they are all by the way
democratic cities which is part of the
reason
uh the administration is being accused
of a political
uh act here essentially you're not
talking about there are republican
cities
with with increased violent crime rates
but but the president hasn't talked
about any of those
right i think you're confusing two
different things portland is unique and
i think people need to understand that
it's a federal courthouse that's being
burned every single night
what the president is referring to what
the department of justice talked about
yesterday and two weeks ago is operation
legend
which is more your violent criminal
activity street crime that you see
with gangs drug dealers and the like
these are two very different things what
we're doing in portland has
nothing to do with that type of criminal
activity what we're doing in portland
again
is seeing criminal activity trying to
burn down the seat of justice
in downtown portland the courthouse and
that is the very small zone that we are
protecting
what we're talking about in chicago
albuquerque and other cities kansas city
is violent criminal activity uh again
gangs drug dealers
and the like so i think your viewers
need to understand these are two very
different things that are occurring
acting secretary will thank you very
much for being with us this morning we
appreciate it